so-called freedom day for england is
going ahead as planned on july
19th bringing freedom from legal
restrictions but not
from covert 19 cases which are on the
rise
prime minister boris johnson is
rebranding the moment asking people to
move forward with caution
not reckless abandon this disease
coronavirus continues to carry risks for
you
and your family we cannot simply revert
instantly
from monday the 19th of july to life
as it was before covid we will stick to
our plan to lift legal restrictions
and to lift social distancing the
changes will see nightclubs and big
performance venues reopen
pub and bar table restrictions and
customer limits abandoned
and the one metre social distancing rule
scrapped
workers will no longer be encouraged to
work from home
and face masks will be recommended but
not compulsory
but a number of top scientists are
concerned saying the government's
decision is not based on scientific
evidence and is dangerous and premature
the basic principle
of managing an outbreak is that you
impose restrictions whenever cases are
going up
and you remove them whenever you're in a
sustained downward trajectory
we seem to be doing the opposite and the
public is divided
going to be good for the whole country i
reckon yeah i really i think people need
a bit of a morale lifter we've been in
lockdown for a long time
i believe they're just thinking about
the economy and i think we're going to
end up in another lockdown again the uk
has suffered one of the highest death
tolls from covert 19
and on monday recorded 34 000 new
infections
but the government says a successful
rollout of the vaccines
has broken the link between cases and
hospitalizations
while scientists say it has merely been
weakened
scrapping all restrictions in the face
of rising infection rates is a gamble
but the government is caught between a
rock and a hard place if it delays it
could potentially
push a third wave further down the line
hitting in winter
when the health service is already under
seasonal strain
but the risks of many people now
developing long covered are real
this is britain as it enters a new
chapter of learning to
live with covert 19. charlie angela al
jazeera
london